Daniel: Hello.
It's July 1, 2023.
We're in “Physics as Information
Processing” in the second discussion.
So thanks all for joining, and we'll see
who else comes in.
If you're watching Live, feel free to
write questions in the Live chat and I'll
relay them onwards.
So Ander,
thanks,
nd it would be awesome to begin with a
little bit of some overview and some
points that you wanted to get to.
Ander: Yeah.
Thank you, Daniel.
So, good morning, everyone.
So if you would start what Chris spoke
about last time.
I have a few slides that I singled out.
So now we're getting to reformulation of
quantum theory in terms of reformulation
of opposed to dynamical theory.
And as we've talked in previous sessions,
we need to think a little bit
philosophically about what the ontology
of measurement entails.
So Chris last lecture started with these
three basic ingredients.
So an action that's, number one, a thing
to ask about.
This is the qubit, the physical degrees
of freedom that we need to perturb in
some way to ask a question.
And then finally, a semantics, a language
that makes sense, a context that makes
sense of that information that we gather.
.
So I should say, number one, I came up in
the first question when I can't exactly
remember.
But at some point, we talked about what
is information?
And we came up with or we brought up a
definition that goes something like this.
.
It's a nice adage.
It's “a differences that make a
difference.”
This is… Chris told me… I can't remember
who first coined this adage, but I think
it's quite old, at least early 70s.
Anyway, so number one, basically perturb
that part, right?
If I want to gather some information, I
need to perturb a system somehow.
So I need to act.
And this is literally in units of actions,
, right?
So units of energy times time.
And he provided the example of rhodopsin,
which is apparently near optimal from a
quantum perspective.
This is mechanically what goes on in your
eyes as light comes in.
And this is clearly the difference that
makes a difference in your brain.
The second part were the physical degrees
of freedom.
So recall that we had a boundary, okay?
So this theory of quantum mechanics as
measurement necessarily breaks down the
system into a bipartite system with a
boundary, which […] are a lot smaller
than the degrees of freedom of A and B,
at least in terms of the dimension of the
Hilbert space and media change.
Daniel: Sorry, can you repeat, Ander?
Ander: Repeat what?
Daniel: Sorry, just last 30 seconds.
Ander: Yeah.
So the second ingredient is the physical
medium in which this information exchange
occurs, where the physical degrees of
freedom, the qubits, are arranged, and
these are physically perturbed in order
to mediate that difference that makes a
difference.
So we can think of this dually as either
preparing those qubits or decoding those
qubits.
And then finally, there was the notion of
the reference frame.
Okay, so the theory necessitates a free
choice of the agent of a reference frame.
.
And physically what this amounts to is a
free choice of a measurement axis for
those qubits.
So we can think of measuring z spin in
those qubits on the boundary.
So that requires a free choice of that
axis.
And this amounts to your reference frame,
the context in which those measurements
are performed.
On one extreme case, we have that if
those references are perfectly aligned,
then the exchange of information is
noiseless.
There.
Was it somewhere over here?
I think I can't quite recall.
But generically, these two reference
frames of Alice and Bob, A and B are not
exactly the same.
They get to choose the reference frames.
I think it's all the way on the bottom,
actually.
Right, so they can be aligned.
If they're aligned, they are exchanging
noiseless information.
Right.
There is no randomness if they are not
superposition onto.
And that's when you're going to get
probabilities in the outcomes.
Trivial probabilities.
So far, so good.
Yes.
Okay, so I have a few more comments of
the main things.
Okay.
It'll take me a few minutes and then we
can chat back and forth.
Perhaps this slide is interesting,
important.
I remember this is where I asked the
question myself, because it's not easy to
wrap your head around what's going on
here.
So we said that measurement and
preparation are completely dual pictures.
.
So this is going to be expanded on in the
next lecture.
But a jerk corollary of that is that if
you prepare Chris said it in similar
terms, if you prepare something in a
certain state and then you measure it
right away, you should expect that it's
still in that state, right?
So, intuitively speaking, this induces a
cycle, right, where you have preparation
and measurement and you're back to square
one, so to speak.
And in generating that cycle, obviously
there has to be some notion of time,
right?
So that's where we're going to have to
make sense of the distinction between
internal and external time.
If we take this measurement operator and
here perform some operations, we can
write it as a unitary propagator from
quantum mechanics, which again preserves
information.
It just leaves the state as it is.
But with this little trick of the week
rotation, you can write it as e to the
measurement up to a constant.
And that precisely encodes, at least
morally speaking, what we just said,
right, that this preparation measurement
thing is a cycle, and more importantly,
it gets rid of this t external time.
And presumably in here it's going to be
replaced by some notion of internal time.
.
We're going to have an internal time QRF,
that is the true local time, as the
observer perceives.
I'm not entirely certain of the details,
but now, looking at it, here the beta,
which presumably there's beta and inverse
temperature here.
I think this is going to be intimately
related to notions of thermal time.
This has been explored in papers by
[Carlo] Rovelli called Internal Time
Reversal[?] [[Rovelli (1993) Statistical
mechanics of gravity and the
thermodynamical origin of time]]. And
Thermal Time is the way in which the
observer observes the passage of time.
Those papers of Rovelli are linked in the
Q and A by the way.
So I can also provide links later.
I think there might have been a question.
.
Should I stop?
Daniel: Yeah, Dean.
Go for it.
Dean: I was curious about this because
what I heard Chris start this session
with was that he was going to try to help
us understand when we are looking at
something through a mechanical lens.
So quantum mechanics and to me this slide
was the way of addressing, as he said his
words were characterized information
transfer in a quantum theoretic way that
the translation from H to M took the
mechanics aspect out of the change or
timepiece.
It was the purification, the most
theoretical form of transfer of
information as opposed to holding up just
the one ordered or sequenced or
mechanical lens.
I heard you ask the question and I kind
of smiled because I thought to myself no,
I understand why Anders is asking this
question.
It's can something be both gripper in the
conceptual meaning sense ontologically
and gripped a physical object.
And I think what I thought maybe I was
misinterpreting.
I'd like what your perspective on this is.
.
That ability to go from H to M is what
allows us to have both the mechanical and
the theoretical.
The transference in its purest sense is
that being able to have both can be true.
.
Is that what it is?
Ander: Yes, for sure.
Yeah.
Much else to say here.
It is true that you can think of the
information transfer picture as an
enlargement or an addition to the
mechanical picture.
And that I don't think that the
mechanical picture has to be just thrown
out completely.
I think it's interesting to keep it to
see how it can be recovered from the
information processing picture.
This reminds me actually there is an
Italian physicist, I think his name is
Kiribella.
And Dean, if you want, I can link you the
papers later who is very fond of the
information theoretical approach to
quantum mechanics and deducing quantum
mechanics from first principles.
And he has a paper, I think the title is
Physics without Physics or something like
that, where he treats this whole thing as
a big seller automaton and by taking
appropriate scaling limits he derives QFT
non interacting QFT.
So he says, okay, let me start with some
axioms how information should be
information processing.
I mean, I'm very loose here.
Then get a cellular automaton out of this
and then take scaling and recover QFT,
non interacting QFT at least.
So start with a few axioms about
information processing, recover mechanics
from that.
Does that add to your question a little
bit?
Dean: Yeah.
All I'm trying to do is tie this back
into some of the live streams that we've
done in the past.
And I know I use different language.
I am not a scientist and I've not studied
quantum other than sort of in passing
ways.
But I do think that what this spoke to me
about was something that I've always
tried to include, which is that there's
the figure it out piece, which to me is
the conceptual and the meaning part that
Chris talked about very clearly here.
And then there's the outing of the figure.
.
There's this sort of physical edge and
boundary that if you don't have an
awareness of both things happening
concurrently the preparation and the
measure are a unitary of sort of minimum
of two state then all bets are off.
In terms of being able to think of these
propagators and operators and all of the
ways that we're trying to explain the
situation they're off.
So we have to have both.
We have to have that sense that there is
a transfer and there is the mechanics.
We have to keep both juggling all the
time.
So that's where this one particular slide
was really quite both bias-confirming for
me.
But I think it also, as you say, is going
to open up a lot that July.
Ander: Yeah, I agree.
I think this might be the most important
or mysterious situation slide.
Dean: Yeah.
And it turns the pyramid, the
conventional approach here's a pyramid
into a top that can be spun [Laughs]
essentially with a Wick rotation.
And it validates how information transfer
probably gets short shrift in most of
this quantum conversation.
But it's probably at least an equal to
the mechanical part.
What order are we delivering this
information in?
At that point
I'll stop.
Daniel: Thanks.
Alexey.
Alexey: Hi, can you hear me?
Daniel: Yes.
Alexey: My mathematics teacher in high
school used to say this is beautiful, but
I don't quite understand it.
So I wanted to maybe I have two questions,
, but I'll start with this simpler one.
So when Chris talked about the reference
frame and said common language, I think
in Shannon common language is the
alphabet.
There's a receiver and Sandra and the
alphabet that they share.
And then Chris said this reference frame
is a physical thing like neurons or hands
or mouth.
And then I got lost because if when I
encode I modify something on the hard
drive, then the physical components of
the hard drive is the reference frame.
But this is not the shared language.
So that's my first question.
Maybe I'll stop here.
I understand we're dealing in metaphors,
but I want to understand that the
reference frame up or down, if Bob and
Alice understand it similarly, then is
that really physical?
Ander: I think answer is that Chris
would
probably give a better answer…
Daniel: Start from the beginning, Ander.
Go.
Ander: … is that both are true at the
same time.
I think Chris would give you a better
answer.
But the semantics or sorry, the sherling,
which a reference frame has to have
physical embodiment and that's a piece of
hardware.
It's a neuron or something.
In this case, it's your free choice of
the spin axis, and that's your reference
frame.
But at the same time, it's it's a
physical it's a physical piece of
hardware.
So reference frames are both the piece of
hardware but also a piece of semantics.
Alexey: So if I take it from the language
I don't quite understand to computer
science.
So if Alice and Bob communicate through a
piece of memory, whether it's Random
Access Memory hard drive, then Alice
encodes something on that hard drive and
Bob reads from the hard drive.
So in that sense, they understand how to
encode and decode, but they use the same
physical piece that's the reference frame.
.
Would that be correct?
Daniel: I might just add one again.
Continuing with the computer science and
the Shannon alphabet, let's just say that
these are plain text character encodings.
.
And so they share the same set of
character, A through Z encodings that is
reflected somewhere physically.
And so if a message were sent from
another letter, it wouldn't render
properly.
It's like outside, they couldn't
differentiate Omega from zeta because
they only have the A through Z software
pack.
And so there's an informational
distinguishment that's facilitated by the
information that's classically inscribed
on the screen, the memory.
And there is an embodied physical as well
as a semantic aspect to that situation.
Alexey: All right, I think I'm getting
closer to understanding.
So, to move away from computer science,
if Ellis is a painter, she took a brush,
dipped it in red paint and painted on the
canvas red.
And Bob has the same understanding of red
as Ellis.
And then he looked at the canvas and red.
.
Red.
Then it is both the physical mark on the
canvas and the symbol of red.
Right?
Ander: Yes.
Daniel: And if somebody had red green
colorblindness that physical apparatus
was not able to informationally
distinguish, then they couldn't make this
wick rotation into the quantum cognitive
space.
They wouldn't be able to detect that
there was a red figure painted on a green
background.
Ander: A key component here is that the
reference frame is inside of the agent.
If you are colorblind, there is something
physical inside of your head or your eyes
or whatever, that does not allow you to
see the difference.
So your semantics are affected ultimately
by a physical piece of hardware.
Alexey: Yeah, maybe I use the bad example,
, because color actually is computed in
the brain and colorblindness is not
necessarily physical.
Okay.
But I think I get it closer.
But if I may ask another question, I get
lost with a saying that preparation and
measurement are they have to happen both.
.
And that when you prepare or when you
read, you modify.
So I am okay with the act of writing, the
act of encoding.
So when I encode something such as I mark
red on the canvas or I write to the hard
drive A, I modify the hard drive.
That is true, but if I am asking a
question right, I am not modifying
anything on the canvas.
So in what way the act of asking the
question or preparation is modifying the
qubit.
This is where I'm lost.
Does that make sense?
Ander: Yeah, I think this is exactly a
question I asked to Chris in in the
stream, so I can't quite remember his
answer.
But I think it was basically that they're
completely dual pictures.
Duality in the sense of they're both two
ways of looking at the same thing,
evolving towards the future, or you have
time symmetry.
You can do either.
Yeah.
So I myself am slightly confused by the
very but I think the answer is that they
are painting at the same the picture of
or am I preparing?
Are just completely dual.
Do you remember that, Daniel?
Yeah.
Okay.
Daniel: I'll give a different angle than
the formal duality relationship.
So let's think about our measuring device
is going to be a carpet, and we're
interested in whether somebody has walked
on the carpet.
So to prepare the carpet, we comb it very
nicely in one direction.
And I'm sure there's analogies there with
the preparation of qubits in a quantum
computer.
But we're going to comb the carpet as an
act of preparation, and then something is
going to happen.
Maybe it's a split second later, and so
we're very confident that it should be
still nicely combed, or maybe it's going
to be a whole working day later.
But now we're going to take that probe,
the tip, whatever it may be, and we're
going to run it along the carpet, and we'
're going to measure the state of the
direction of the fibers of the carpet.
So if we didn't prepare the measurements,
we wouldn't have a calibrated reference
point to know how things had even changed.
.
And so there's a cycle of preparing the
apparatus through something like a
calibration or at least like an emptying
of memory, to be able to then make an
observation and to have that observation
have the kind of meaning that we would
have expected, like purge the photo
detector, make the measurement.
Now you have to purge it again.
That's the preparation.
What do you think, Alexey?
Alexey: That is a beautiful metaphor, and
I dig that, except I think I heard Chris
say that when you prepare, you may qubit
into up or down.
And this is what I'm lost, because when
you comb the carpet, you don't do that.
You don't put the footstep on it.
In fact, there may not be any footstep.
Dean: Right.
Alexey: And this is where I'm missing, I
think, in quantum physics as well.
If you measure the cause and effect,
relationships are broken here for me, if
in my act of preparation, I'm opening my
canvas to read the message, but I do not
know what the message will be, I'm game.
But if he's saying that when I prepare, I
modify the carpet such that it becomes
either up or down, actually not blank,
but up or down.
Then I'm lost.
Daniel: You have to comb the carpet up or
down.
There's no blank carpet.
So you have an Etch A Sketch.
You could either make all the pixels
white and then you'd be able to measure a
message in the dark or you can make all
the message dark or the slate dark, and
then you could be able to measure
something that was light, but you pick a
direction of polarization in your
preparation or calibration step so that
deviations from that can be the
measurement.
Alexey: So you're saying carpet is
binary?
Carpet doesn't have multiple states.
Carpet can only have two states.
So if I prepare it, I effectively put it
in one of those states.
Daniel: Well, let's say we had the carpet
at a 45 degree angle.
Mathematically we could describe that as
a mixed state, and it may not be the most
effective for measuring the movement of
people across the carpet, but yeah, you
could define it or comb it that way.
If it were only a binary, it wouldn't be
a qubit then it would be a classical bit,
actually.
Yeah, under.
Go for it.
Ander: Yeah.
If I recall lecture a couple of slides
more, we briefly talked about it like ten
minutes ago.
By preparing, you are choosing an axis
and whatever you up or down in that axis.
.
Now, that doesn't mean that the
environment gets to do its own thing,
right?
And superposition of outcomes, but at
least you're measuring in that axis,
right?
So it's going to be either up or down in
that two pictures.
I just want to see a few words on screens,
, on the fine line diagrams and maybe
clarify question a little more.
Daniel: Dean.
Dean: On this.
Really interesting.
I don't know how metaphorically you could
explain the carpet as a wave, but I think
once you get away from the it's up or
down, that possibility enters the
conversation.
And the only reason I wonder whether or
not metaphorically, the wave aspect of
that can be included in how you're
describing the carpet is that Chris spent
quite a bit of time on the all possible
paths argument.
And in particular, and I love this, when
Alice isn't looking right.
Well, in that wave equation, how could
Alice not be looking?
That's what gets real.
I mean, Alice could not be looking if it'
's binary, if it's or up or down, but if
it's wave, it's on.
It's a unitary propagator.
I'm not sure how she takes her eyes off
of this preparation measure thing that's
going off all the time.
So this is actually what I consider to be
a feature or an opportunity or an opening
in the sense that from a strictly
information transfer piece not a
mechanical piece now, not a physical
thing from an information transfer piece,
maybe the carpet can be metaphorically
understood as a wave.
That the eyes of Alice or whoever's doing
the preparing and the measuring.
Bob, Alice.
I don't care.
Peaches that there is actually a
difference, then between something that
is exchanged and something that is
informationally transferred.
And again, I don't think that the four of
us here sitting right now are going to
resolve that.
But I wonder if part of the difficulty in
this is finding the physical metaphor
that explains the theoretical transfer in
such a way that both breaks the symmetry
and holds it.
Because again, we're back to gripper and
grip.
We're back to figuring it out and outing
the physical figures in the state that we'
're in.
And we have to do both at once.
So again, Daniel, you're the creative guy.
.
How do you turn your carpet metaphor into
a wave equation?
Daniel: Maybe there's a subwoofer in the
room or maybe somebody is waving the
carpet.
But what you said about what is exchanged
and what is transferred, maybe the
transfer is the classical component.
I don't know which one will be exchange
or transferred, but one of them is the
classical inscription.
That's how many gigabytes were written or
read to the hard drive.
But what's exchanged, let's just say, are
the semantics of meaning.
And given an appropriate Copeparation,
maybe only one bit needs to be
transferred for the exchange of a message
that was already triggered to be set off.
.
And then also, this entire discussion, it
kind of strikes me as like the Cartesian
duality of our time.
But rather than mind and body, it's the
physicality of information syntax and the
metaphysicality of information semantics.
.
And that's these kind of two worlds with
their own physics and metaphysics that we'
're trying to connect.
And it's like, similarly well, how does
the information world cause something
physical?
How does the physical cause somethingal?
And I think that the entire journey that
the course and everyone is on is physics
as information processing, those as a
qualified and distinguished but minimum
of two set.
Alexey?
Alexey: Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Can you hear me?
Ander: Yeah.
Alexey: Thinking out loud?
Ander: Maybe.
Alexey: But I think the way to get closer
to understanding in my head is to let go
of the metaphor of asking a question,
right?
So if Alexi is talking to Daniel through
zoom and I pose even a closed question,
up or down.
So I formulated the question and released
it into zoom space.
And then I'm silent and I opened my
listening to your answer.
But you, Daniel, have agency to say up or
down.
I do not have any effect on whether you
will say up or down.
Right?
That's the difference.
So me asking you a question does not
modify the answer.
You decide.
Alice talking to Bob.
Bob has the agency to answer the question,
, not Alice.
And that's where I'm stuck.
So I don't know if asking a question
continues to be a good metaphor.
Preparing the instrument for measurement
is maybe better.
But actually, Ellis is not asking Bob.
Ellis is acting on a qubit.
Right.
And qubit is is a simple thing that, you
know, can can literally physically be up
or down, I guess.
And so that's that's maybe, maybe that's
the answer that Ellis is not asking.
Bob Ellis does something to the qubit and
because qubit can be up or down, then
that's no longer asking a question.
Asking a question implies your
correspondent can tell you anything.
Daniel: When we're dealing with the very
sophisticated process of natural language
question asking, I think we're dealing
with something that's orders of
composition above the kind of binary ask.
.
So I agree with that.
It's almost like Alice prepares the
photoreceptor so its slate is refreshed
and then it's the photon or the light
emitting object that has the agency to
send the photon or not.
I mean, maybe the preparation occurs and
then no one comes back to check whether
or not agency was even exerted.
And I think when we really focus on the
nanoprobe like atomic force microscopy,
really tracing with a super fine tip over
the surface of something, or scattering X
rays, when we really think about the
moment of information transfer, we
realize like, nothing comes for free.
And I think that this question asking
framework, other than really conveniently
rederriving quantum mechanics in 1 hour
incredibly helps us understand that we
don't get to ask it for free in terms of
time.
We don't get to ask.
It for free in terms of energy.
And we don't get to ask free floating
questions where the question and or
agentic responder are not involved
already in a semantics.
So I think it's calling attention to the
components of an experiment or a question
or an opening.
But agree that it's not always as simple
as a binary question, but in the special
simple basal case, it does start there.
Do you want to look at any of the
participant submitted questions, if there
was any that struck your let me finish
real quick.
Ander: I had like maybe five minutes to
wrap this up.
And this, I think, is going to, at least
in part, answer one of Dean's concerns.
So the next thing we should very briefly
cover, let's talk a little bit about
Holographic screens.
And also this is the paper on the
physical meaning of Holographic principle.
.
So let's take a look at also this picture
from that paper.
This is the Holographic boundary and
Landauer's principle and all these
thermodynamic constraints on information
processing necessitate the breakdown of
this boundary in terms of free energy
extraction sectors, memory sectors and so
on.
And by the way, if you read the
paragraphs around this picture, there's
more details on how the time QRF is
induced, but we'll leave that as it is
for now.
Dean, what I meant by this answering your
concern, was that you don't see how Alice
can take off her eyes from the picture.
But that's precisely what's going on here,
, right?
There's a sector that's being observed,
which is a subset of these qubits that
are being observed, but presumably she
has the freedom to say, hey, this sector.
.
Now I declare as my observation sector,
this I declare as my memory sector, this
I declare as my thermal free energy
extraction sector.
So it is because of these fundamental
limits on the amount of information
processing, it is not true that she can
she doesn't have an idealized Laplacian,
if you wish, access to all the degrees of
freedom.
She can only observe, finally, a finite
amount of stuff.
So she is forced to take her eyes off at
least part of the system, at least for a
while, right?
Because otherwise all those energy and
time constraints that Daniel was just
mentioning, they're not you have to abide
by those.
A few things that Chris mentioned in the
last lecture when it came to this
holographic screen is, well, number one,
that all the information exchange is
mediated by bits here at the qubits, at
this holographic screen.
This in turn enforces a finiteness in the
information transfer, if you wish.
There is not an infinite amount of
information in finite space.
Even if you were to pack it at Plankian
density, which is presumably the limit
that black holes achieve, it's still a
finite amount of information in a finite
amount of so if you have finite ones, you
are taking the other is the following.
And again, Chris will deal with this at
greater detail in perhaps lecture five, I
think maybe four.
But it's the notion of emergent spacetime,
, which is that A and B separately.
So you think of these are presumably the
internal degrees of freedom, what's going
on inside of a alice, at an abstract
level, there may not be a notion of space,
, but notion of space emerges at the
boundary.
And that's not easy to explain, I think,
presumably has to do with and stuff like
that.
And I don't know the full details myself,
but for now, that's one of the key things
that Chris mentioned, which is that an
agent may not have space, but it may
emerge boundary.
The last thing, and I'm glad that to see
that this was mentioned already, so it
saves us time.
I don't have to say it again.
Take us a minute.
And this again answers your can you.
Daniel: Just turn off your video under
just so you don't have lag?
Ander: Yeah.
Thank you.
1 second.
Yes.
Can you yeah me.
Go for it.
This notion of Feyman diagrams, right?
So what is this whole thing about unitary
evolution or preparation?
The scattering picture as Alice preparing
as her of her boundary and writing it
into her memory and then measuring it at
some point in the future requires that
you consider the possible that happened
to that preparation.
Okay.
So if there's some amount of time passes,
you prepared your state at time T, you
look at it again at time T plus DT, you
have to take into account all.
The possible histories, clearly, of the
system, or at least that part of the
system.
Writing it's, just saying, I prepared it
here, now it's up to b what happens until
the next time I look at it, up to the
environment.
So in that unitary evolution, I consider
all the possibilities.
Right, and that's exactly so.
Let's just look at the conclusion.
We will leave it there for now.
We can open up the discussion.
So there's two things that are now, where
was this?
Go ahead.
Dean: Yeah, I understand.
Or I think I understand.
I think I understand that if I'm looking
at on or if I'm attending to on, I'm not
looking at off.
What I saw in that wave thing with
Federman was I could also be looking at
the switch where the two different places
of on and off exist.
And when I'm looking at the entire switch,
, I'm not looking at one or the other, I'
'm looking at that basil, as Daniel
described, that Basil opportunity of both.
.
And I think that on that I don't know how
that ties in with reference frames, but
on that level that says, I'm now looking
at all possible in that moment.
I don't think, at least from that
perspective, that reference frame I'm
zooming into an on or off binary choice
decision branch.
I'm still at that place where the
preparation allows for both.
I'm literally not taking my eyes off at
that place.
So, again, I'm not arguing with you
because what you described and the image
that you brought up, all that is is
bringing it down to a granular level and
saying if I'm paying attention to this, I
can't be paying attention to that.
But if I physically, from a transfer
perspective, back up so that I can see
both possibilities at once, I don't know
that I'm taking my eye off of either.
That's the only thing that I was bringing
up.
Now, of course, Chris will probably hear
this and go, dean, you got to go and
rethink this whole thing through, which
is great because I'm here to learn.
But again, if I misspoke about what I was
trying to say, it wasn't because I don't
see those moments when I'm directing my
preparation over here.
And that's going to give me one kind of
measurement versus if I'm taking in a
larger time frame or larger spatial frame
or larger holographic screen.
Like I don't even know how to describe it
because I just don't have the words for
it yet.
But there you go.
I just want to be clear that I'm not I
don't think I'm confused.
I just want to know the difference
between when I'm looking at on or off and
when I'm looking at the entire switch.
That's all.
Daniel: I'll add one point on this slide.
.
It goes back to some of the earliest
points that Chris made about the
ontological primacy of communication.
Space and time arise from communicating
agents.
Communicating agents are not something
that we have to squeeze into an a priori
spatial temple framework.
So quantum mechanics saying here on the
slide is about measurement, not
mechanical motion.
So we don't need to wait around or
speculate as to how from the quote
mechanical or physical hard drive
measurement arises or happens.
We start with the measurement occurring
and then different kinds of sophisticated
agents can conceptualize of movement
through spaces and times.
And this also relates to Bayesian
mechanics as a mechanics and a physics of
movement on information geometric spaces.
.
And so the physics can be projected by
appropriately prepared agents, but we don'
't necessarily need to wonder about how
that agent fits within a mechanical
setting.
And I guess this is where humans are with
the I am a strange loop girdle escher
Bach gripper and gripped mystery of being
able to see it multiple ways.
Ander, do you want to go to the
questions?
Ander: Yeah, let me just say closing
remarks here.
I think what Chris is punching line of
the paper free energy principle for
quantum systems, which is morally
speaking, it's similar to relaxation to
thermodynamical equilibrium, which is
that if you have an isolated bipartite
quantum system, a and B are going to turn
are going to tend towards reference frame
alignment and therefore entanglement.
And these two things are basically very
intimately related.
By aligning the reference frame culia amb
will be driven towards maximal
entanglement.
So should I take a look at the questions
and open this?
Yeah, so so if you guys have access to
the Q and A, there's been more questions
in the last bringing you guys'attention
to a few of them.
This is where Chris links to the papers
of Robelli, which I mentioned earlier in
passing when we were talking about the
preparation, measurement cycle and the
notion of formal time or subjective time,
if you wish, as somebody brought up this
remark that performance and calculations
here you can relate t time to a change in
a change in the volume of face space, or
more precisely, the amount of available
states in the state space, with a log and
whatever with respect to the energy.
Right?
So this restates the idea that we're
talking about earlier, right?
Like your intrinsic subjective time being
this DS the eitherative thermal time
basically speaking, that is observer
dependent.
So that's a good question to take a look
at.
There's another one.
What is meant by local free of choice?
This is a very good answer too.
Local here means a Sam boundary, right?
Isolated systems are idealized by
definition.
There's always going to be an observer
interacting with an environment.
So an ISO purely isolated system is an
idealization.
So what local free choice means here is
exactly what we said earlier, right?
That you get to choose the spin axis at
the boundary qubits.
There were some nice questions relating
mark of blankets to the scattering
picture.
So this one, for instance, is also worth
a look.
So somebody brought up this very good
point about the scattering matrix.
Scattering matrix is by the way, let's
not think about it mathematically, let's
think about the picture, right?
You imagine two particles that are
interacting and far away they are free,
right?
They are specially separated and
interacting free particles.
And somehow at some point they come to
interact, right?
And then you have to write all the finite
diagrams for all the exchange of bosons
or whatever the interaction is.
And that's how you would compute the
amplitudes for the scattering process,
right?
How those two particles that were
separated came to interact and then they
go off to infinity again.
Chris here brings up the point that in a
sense, how you define a Markov blanket is
in the opposite direction, right?
Marko blanket in at least in the graph
theory sense, you start with a node.
The marker blanket is just the set of
nodes that separate in terms of
conditional probability, that node from
everyone else.
And then you can have edges which are
going to be directly coastal network, so
acyclic, no cycles directed edges.
That's how the graph looks.
And you build up essentially you're
taking the opposite picture, right?
You start with a node, which in this case
would be the interaction, and then you
build up to infinity as opposed to in the
scattering picture, which is like you
start with particles not interacting at
infinity.
You see how they go off to infinity again
and then the interaction is in the middle.
.
So obviously the answer is a bit more
precise, but it's worth taking a look at.
.
And this is an interesting one too, of a
symmetrical input output bandwidth.
So again, if you think of it as a graph,
nothing is constraining you to say that
you're going to have more incoming arrows
than outcoming arrows into the boundary.
Right?
That's just the way it is.
If you think of it, a graph, there is no
symmetry imposed.
The only natural sense of symmetry would
be energy conservation.
And that's exactly what Chris says here,
right, which is that, and I'm not sure
myself how you relate it to a
conservation of not quite information,
but I wouldn't know how to phrase it
myself.
I would just take a look at the question.
.
But basically, no, there is a priority
nothing that necessitates symmetry input
output in mark of blankets.
But if you are to talk about any sort of
symmetry, the natural language would not
be in terms of incoming versus outcome in
arrows, but rather energy conservation,
which we saw is a close casting of
information transfer, right, because of
the minimal requirements for action to
rewrite a qubit.
And the last question that I would like
to bring your guys'attention to, I mean,
all of them are great, but we have finite
resources and finite times on internet
would be would be this one.
Okay.
And I'm not going to go into too much
detail.
But this is again about the local wait 1
second.
Turn on my camera, by the way.
Daniel: Dino, go for it.
And also people can see all the questions
on the website, right?
And submit their own as well.
Ander: Yes, for sure.
So now I lost track of the question that
I wanted to show you guys.
I think it's this one over here.
Yes, exactly.
This one.
By the way, all of them are good, even
this one, the Holographic principle, does
it make it easier to compute any physics
problems?
Well, please take a look at Chris's
answer.
But all I can say is that these ideas of
holography, I'm not an expert, I'm not a
condensed matter physicist, but they're
used all over physics nowadays, not
necessarily just in high energy.
I know that condensed matter theorists
use them all the time.
So the answer to this is an emphatic yes,
the Holographic, at least Ada Saft is
used all over.
But again, I'm not a physicist myself, so
this is the last question I wanted to
bring your attention to.
And here Chris, this may be the one worth
taking a look at in terms of in order to
answer all the earlier speculations that
we had about time internal clock, here
somebody asks about synchrony and just
the perception of time with respect to
external clocks, I suppose.
And Chris here answers that at the end of
the day, even if you're using an external
clock, everything that you perceive
outside at the end of the day has to be
in terms of an internal clock.
Any information incoming, you're going to
have to make causal sense of it, you're
going to have to write it into a memory.
In terms of an internal clock, you're
never going to be able to, so to speak,
increase your precision of the passage of
time by taking that external clock, even
if you think it's more precise than
anything you have inside.
I think that's basically what his answer
amounts to.
And this is morally related to all this
frame halting problem stuff where because
as a system, you're never going to give
an infinitely precise I'm speaking very
loosely here an infinitely precise
description of yourself.
You're never going to morally speaking
again, that's what it amounts to.
You're never going to be able to outdo
your internal clock by trying to leverage
something external like an atomic clock,
that even if you think it's more precise,
at the end of the day, your own
subjective perception of information will
depend on internal clocks.
So we can open up things.
Any concluding remarks and any other
Alexey or Dean or anyone else who may
have joined?
I don't have anything else to say at this
point.
Daniel: I mean, where or when are we?
We had session one with a real big
historical overview.
Section two, we focused on the
Measurability question, which is answered
with a question, and we talked about some
of the constraints of question asking,
namely that it takes time, it takes
energy, you have to ask it to somebody or
something on an interface, and it has to
have a semantic quantum reference frame.
And this is dovetailing with a free
energy principle, of course, because the
free energy principle, as it says in the
syllables, to what does the free energy
principle apply?
And Chris says everything.
Measurable.
That's why it's a theory of everything
that we choose to measure and model, not
ontological statements about what is.
And then where are we heading into in
session three?
Have you looked ahead, Ander, or do you
want me to read what's in the syllabus?
Ander: Please do.
Yeah, I think basically my short answer
to that, and possibly my full answer also,
, is that it's just going to take care of
the loose ends in this lecture two.
So this lecture two is a warm up to the
real thing, which we need to talk more
seriously about reference frames in order
to get the precise picture of this
quantum measurement process.
Daniel: Yeah, it says that session three
will introduce the idea of quantum
reference frames and the representation
using Hierarchies of binary classifiers.
These formal structures provide a
semantics for measurement and hence
provide the basis for a theory of meaning
for interacting agents.
The language of QRFs allows a
particularly straightforward and
intuitive definition of variational free
energy, and so allows a fully general
quantum formulation of the FEP.
We will see that the FEP is a classical
limit on the principle of unitarity, the
fundamental principle of quantum theory.
Ander: By the way, Danielle, I'm not sure
if you're busy, but I just got an email
from Chris.
I think he may be watching us and I think
he's just confused about the link.
Chris, I don't know if you're there still,
, but do you think it's worth it?
We send him the link real quick if he can
come for a few minutes.
Yeah.
Daniel: I'll send Chris the zoom link now.
.
Yeah, hold on to your qubit, Chris, we're
coming.
Ander: Yeah, so let's give him a few
minutes.
Maybe he's still watching and he'll
answer the questions better than I could.
.
Dean: Well, Daniel is sending him a
lifeline.
Just from the rookie perspective on this
session one seemed like there was a big
time window, like the historical piece
over using an external clock and a
timeline.
This one felt like the parabola and the
upper down and the entanglement was
almost instantaneous in terms of that
plank length that we were really holding
up as comparative to that timeline, that
chronological timeline.
And so I'm guessing that now that we've
established those two as different, where
does that go?
But again, that's just the rookies view
of things.
Daniel: Hey, Chris.
Welcome.
Chris: Yeah, hi.
This is a very interesting discussion and
it's given me some pointers as to what to
emphasize at the beginning of session
three.
But I can say in response to Dean's
question that the time when Alice isn't
looking is the time during which Bob is
making his measurement and then his next
preparation step.
So if you consider again that slide that
shows sort of the Feynman representation
of what's happening as this unitary flow,
that's what Bob is doing.
And I think Ander said that from Alice's
point of view, bob is just some quantum
system and she's banged on that system by
asking a question.
And now that system is doing something or
other that she can't see until Bob bangs
on his side of the screen and she gets
some information.
By making a measurement, she may be not
looking for a very short period of time.
Right.
According to her internal clock.
She's not looking for just the time it
takes for one of her internal ticks to
take place.
But in general, we're not saying anything
about how long that time is, right?
If you think of this in a scattering
theory way, then we're talking about the
time between two protons leaving the
rings on the Large Hadron Collider to the
time that all the stuff that comes out of
their collision is measured by the
detectors, which is a nanosecond or
something like that, some very short
period of time.
So just think of that interval as the
measure of the intrinsic time dependence,
external time dependence of the
interaction.
Someone has to do something and then
someone else has to do something.
And there's a gap between what the first
person does and what they see in response.
.
Let's see what's the other question the
other central question that came up today
was the question of why observing
something requires action.
And of course, in the classical picture,
observing something doesn't require any
action at all.
The event just happens.
And this is the fundamental, if you will,
distinction between classical and quantum
theory is that making an observation in
quantum theory is taking an action on the
world.
And there's a lovely metaphor that's not
correct in detail but it's very useful, I
think, conceptually which heisenberg came
up with to try to explain his uncertainty
principle to his classical colleagues.
He said, look, suppose I'm trying to see
a very small particle and measure its
motion.
I have to have a microscope to see this
particle and to measure its motion.
I need to light it up.
I need to shine some light on it.
And those photons of light are actually
impacting the thing I'm trying to see.
So the act of observation itself requires
banging something into an object.
And when we're just looking out at the
world, it's the sun that's banging the
light into the object, not us.
But we can sort of merge those two
systems together because it's the sun
that's taking the action that lets us get
some information.
But the sun is perturbing the things that
we're looking at by banging photons into
them.
And I think that picture of Heisenberg's
is what he used to actually derive the
uncertainty principle in terms of
momentum and position, because banging
something into something is transferring
momentum to it.
Photons transfers the momentum to the
tiny particle in the microscope, and that
perturbs its position on the microscope
stage, which is precisely what heisenberg
is trying to measure.
So that's his point in that analogy.
Observation itself always takes action.
And that's why observation and
preparation are duals in quantum theory,
because they each require a minimum one
unit of action.
And I think, Ander, you said the duality
can be thought of in terms of time
invariance, and that's exactly correct.
Preparation is just measurement run
backwards and vice versa.
Ander: And if you let me say a few words,
I think this also answers my own
confusion and the one that Alexey the
question that Alexi posed earlier, which
is this duality between preparation and
measurement in your picture that you're
bringing up Chris with heisenberg by
shining photons on particle that I'm
trying to observe.
These pictures of preparation and
measurement are dual because in doing so,
I'm constraining the system.
In trying to measure it, I'm constraining
it.
In me trying to gather information by
shining photons on it.
What I'm really doing is I'm constraining
it.
I'm just saying you can only take this
moment or position.
Would that be correct?
Chris: Yeah.
In fact, in the microscope example, it's
particularly clear you're bouncing a
photon off of the object, and then it's
that photon that you're detecting.
Right.
There was one other question that can be
answered quickly.
It was the question about what's the
reference frame that Alice is using when
she's measuring up or down, measuring her
spin up or down.
And of course, there are several
reference frames involved here, so let's
work inwards in a real system.
Alice is sitting here.
She's got a Stern Girlock apparatus,
which is a vertical magnet apparatus, and
she's measuring the spin of an electron
that's traveling through this Stern
Girlock device.
And what the Stern Girlock device does is
orient the spin with a magnetic field
that's not homogeneous, so it ends up
pointing physically up as it comes
through the apparatus.
So how is that apparatus oriented?
I mean, what defines the up direction for
that apparatus?
Well, in the practical setting, what
defines that apparatus orientation is the
Earth's gravitational field.
Right.
We're here in the laboratory, and the
Earth's gravitational field tells us what
direction is down.
It's toward the center of the Earth, and
so up is away from the center of the
Earth, and that's what defines the axis
for the apparatus, which is a great big
piece of metal.
So it's very responsive to the
gravitational field.
So now we can ask about Alice.
Right.
Alice is also embedded in this
gravitational field, and she also can
detect the gravitational field.
She can tell which way is down toward the
center of the Earth by the force acting
on her feet.
And that measurement is taking place in
Alice's brain.
So in Alice's brain, there's a
representation of which way is up, and
that's the internal reference frame of
Alice that lets her do the experiment.
If she was freely floating in space, but
the apparatus was anchored to the
gravitational field, she wouldn't be able
to tell that it was anchored to the
gravitational field.
That's Einstein's point that Einstein
makes in all of those experiments where
he has observers flying around in
spacecraft that they have to have their
own reference frame.
What Einstein didn't emphasize was that
reference frame is in their head.
It's encoded by their nervous system.
So I think it was Daniel who said this
exactly correctly, that the physical
object in her head, the the actual neural
network that tells her which way the
gravitational field is, is itself a
semantic object.
That's what gives the word up and down
meaning for Alice.
What do I mean when I say the word
meaning?
I mean, it lets her take some action.
Semantics boils down to actionability if
it gives things significance.
And this was the point that Bateson was
making when he said, differences that
make a difference for an organism,
something is meaningful if it actually
makes a difference for what I can do in
this world that I'm trying to survive in.
.
So I'll leave it at that.
But this is very useful for leading off
the next session.
So thank you very much for all that
discussion.
Daniel: Awesome.
Thank you.
Ander: I guess if I could say one thing
here is that let me scroll back up to the
three points early in the slides.
Differences that make a difference would
tell you that you require action to
perturb a system and measure.
And then the semantics or the
contextuality that may be encoded in the
nervous system would tell you what is the
difference that is being made.
Would that be correct?
Chris: Yeah.
Right.
What tells you that there's a difference
there?
It's what you're able to detect and
represent internally.
Daniel: It's almost like step one, do
differently.
Step two, you have to ask it to a
different thing.
And then three, you need the semantic
frame that makes A and B different
differences all the way down.
Well, we will transcribe this and fix the
few patchy moments ender.
We'll work together on updating the
transcript so that everybody who wants to
be well prepared for the measurement of
the third lecture will be absolutely in
place.
Thank you, Chris, for joining.
That's a fun cap to this discussion.
Chris: So, all right, thank you.
Daniel: See you all next time.
Ander: Bye.